[Music]
be
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i'm not even sure if devastated would
actually summarize what we are feeling
right now
it is suffocating to say at least it is
very suffocating his absence has
impacted all of us
so there is always a danger of getting
arrested there is always
a threat of being targeted at the end of
the day it's our choice we have chosen
this field of journalism to put things
on right perspective and along with that
the danger
[Music]
i do not see fahad's arrest as an
isolated incident
it is obviously in line with
several other summons or
cases that kashmir walla has been facing
or even other journalists and kashmir
have been facing for their work for
writing basic reports not even op-eds
analysis if you are working in a
conflict zone like kashmir there is
always a danger
not from one side but both sides i mean
you never know what is going to happen
to you in journalism uh you have to tell
the truth and
you can't keep everybody happy by
telling the truth
[Music]
here in kashmir we have a very young
team i mean
most of our stuffers are in 20s
so it has impacted them
in terms of
you know
the work and of course like i shouldn't
say the word threat but you know there
is some apprehensions
there they wanted to you know contribute
to the society they wanted to uphold the
truth the basic principle is what
journalism teaches us but straight away
now seeing this kind of you know
atmosphere where
you know you are being pushed against
the wall you are being watched you are
being monitored your stories are being
actually criticized
uh because you know quote unquote that
didn't you know it doesn't uh hold uh
the current dispensation in uh you
[Music]
i don't think i need to say anymore that
if we or any other person sees that sees
this entire series of event as violation
of press freedom or our rights as
journalists
i think it is out there in open
for
you all to decide it now
[Applause]
[Music]
you